good morning Hank it's Sunday it's
Newsday pride is one of the seven deadly
sins but little known fact nerd pride is
one of the seven lively virtues Hank
since it's Newsday today I'm going to
tell you about some recent problems in
the publishing industry and I'm going to
do so using my beloved medium of text
remember text but since I know that
would be incredibly boring we're gonna
augment the video with Argyle the
one-eyed book reading sock puppet and
black Santa they're gonna have a dance
party while listening to a song from
your new CD
[Music]
I'd seen your videos and I think they're
so jokes and now we're getting Ferdie
with a couple Facebook posts I confess
that I've adapted to your time Joe at
least now I don't have to want you to
Oh even now
I'd much rather touch you
whoa cheery nerdfighter like with me
watch you stay up all night on skype
with me good day to the library too bad
you don't live anywhere near me
take lunch we blurb some love books and
blenderize our meals all of the tables
gave us dirty looks do a reading of the
get stuck in my pants
we could hang out IRL I do my happy
dance so even though tonight I got a
date with my bookshelf
I'd much rather touch and hug you
maybe something else
won't you be interred fine like me won't
you stay up on my skype with me we
slow-danced to music that's royalty-free
you don't leave Annie
near me
[Music]
oh you moves and not a god the date with
my bookshelf
I'd much rather touching hug you
and something
[Applause]
won't you be like me won't you stay up
all night on skype me
- but you don't live anywhere near me
that's too bad
I screwed up at the end that